hi mr shapiro howdy i'm actually the
president of the college democrats
well thank you for coming and thank you
for co-sponsoring i appreciate it thank
you thank you for coming
now good question are you the guy who
protested me outside or are you the guy
we were having a bake sale
actually oh really yeah that's lower the
cookies good at least yep
really good cookies fantastic were they
legal
not yet give it time
so my question to you relates
specifically to the transgender issue
that you showed up during your speech
you cite the ucla study and claim that
it doesn't show in any way that suicide
rates go down post out
you say there's no evidence verifying
this however
during your speech i said there's mixed
evidence i said there's mixed evidence
about that about the during your
scenario i pulled up the study on my
phone as well as
as well as a bevy of other studies uh
looking at research from the
kerolinskene institute from berlin
scientists it actually seems to suggest
specifically the berlin study that
suicide attempt rates dropped from 26
percent to three percent in post office
right so i've seen that study also one
of the problems with that particular
studies it's not longitudinal that study
is only about like one year after the
surgery
and what you actually what the
statistics tend to show at least
according to
scientists on the other side right is
that you have to wait 10 years to find
out whether
the surgery takes or not essentially
that that there is an adjustment period
that of course you're really enthused in
the year after you get a surgery that
you feel you've been eating in your
entire life
but there's a readjustment period that
happens so for example here's another
longitudinal study it's a cohort study
from sweden
it was released in 2011 it covered sex
reassignment surgeries from 1973 to
2003. this is a 30-year
longitudinal study and it found that
transgender surgery recipients were
still 19 times more likely to die by
suicide than the general population
and found that quote sex reassignment
although alleviating gender dysphoria
may not suffice as treatment for
transsexualism right so
there as i say there is mixed data i'm
not saying those studies don't exist
i'm saying i do find severe flaws in
some of the studies that are cited
a lot of them are cited due to small
sample size or or not enough time in the
longitudinal
oh yeah thank you follow up thank you
but specifically regarding the ucla
study it actually suggests that when
people are in supportive environments
their suicide attempt rates go down
you said that you do not believe feeding
into their quote delusion will support
them
how do you respond to the ucla study you
yourself use suggesting that it in fact
does so
a lot of these so i i don't tend to
believe self-reported studies about
treatment
and the meaning of how people treat you
still for question questionnaire studies
are not as good as behavioral studies so
the more important statistic from that
study the one that i usually cite is the
one about whether people can identify
you as transsexual or
as transgender or not right if they
can't identify you as transgender it's a
lifetime suicide suicidality suicide
attempt rape
and if you are not identified as
transgender there's a 40
lifetime suicide attempt right now that
doesn't mean that
if people are mean to you that your life
isn't worse or that your suicide rate
may not go up maybe it does
but i think that the evidence is not
particularly strong on that score
and the level of bullying has you have
to really have some sort of third party
documentation it's the level of bullying
because there's also the possibility the
significant possibility that people who
are more likely to commit suicide
are also more likely to feel sensitive
to bullying that other people not
might not feel sensitive to thank you
for coming out i hope you enjoy the
weather